[Music]
you can't deal with these people there's
no need to try there's no need to talk
to them
[Music]
i think israelis have to take over
allah muhammad who's one of the ufc
fighters had on his instagram
most jewish people don't live in israel
many jewish people always opposed israel
many jewish people rejected zionism
there's only one way like i would carpet
bomb them
you would harp on them it's the only
it's the only way you could deal with it
some of the videos that you sent me of
soldiers shooting at people
that are not doing anything right we
need to kill a harvest
[Laughter]
[Music]
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dean show i'm eddie your
host
and my next guest abby martin is an
american journalist tv presenter and
activist she's also the director of
gaza fights for freedom now before we
bring her on
let's go ahead and get into her
documentary and then we'll
bring our special guest on israel treats
every palestinian with the presumption
that they're a terrorist
painting itself as the true victim
[Music]
gaza has a story if you look at mass
media the story you find is that they
fire hundreds of rockets into israeli
cities
right across the border everything
before that point is left out
most commonly we hear of rockets hitting
the border city of stair road
it is home to the notorious stair road
cinema where settlers drink beer and eat
popcorn watching bombs fall onto gaza
stair road was once called hajj a
village that was 100
palestinian and muslim israeli historian
benny morris uncovered that not only did
palestinian residents get along well
with jewish
settlers but they actually hidden
protected them from british occupation
forces in 1946
when a british army dragnet was rounding
up members of a jewish paramilitary
the palestinians of hajj kept them safe
it came as a shock to them when just
about a year later
that same paramilitary violently
expelled every single resident of hajj
all fled to gaza hajj was renamed stare
wrote
go ahead and subscribe right now hit
that notification bell help us get our
numbers back up did you know that
many years ago the dean show when we
started 2006 we used to broadcast for
many years on the khalifa clothing
channel
currently known as digital men but so
we're trying to get our numbers back up
because the channel
at that time got closed then we started
the official d show channel we're trying
to get our numbers back up to where they
should be
and that's this number here 855 combined
what we currently have 442 we should be
over a million
200 000 subscribers
help us to get our numbers back to where
they should be with that small setback
that we had many years ago
you guys can help us by subscribing
right now and hitting that notification
bell
thank you very much enjoy the rest of
this show
and don't forget to support us on our
patreon page and this is abby
martin the director of gaza
fights for freedom how are you abby i'm
doing great how are you
it's really an honor to have you on the
dean show thank you for being with us
so tell us uh you are someone who is
really
taken to this topic here of israel and
palestine how did you get involved in
this yeah i think it really just comes
uh in conjunction with kind of an
awareness about the
war on terror and u.s imperialism and
looking at the world through the lens of
u.s
empire back when 9 11 happened which is
kind of my awakening point i remember
that the u.s political establishment
and the media actually first
directed our attention to palestinians
um
and um i'll never forget that problem
that was
out there to conflate palestinians with
terrorists
and then of course israeli officials
were paraded around our media
saying now you can embark on your own
war on terror using israel as the
blueprint
um so really since that day
kind of my my larger awareness was
awakened about palestine and of course
just meeting palestinians
um getting to know people who were
affected directly
by what's going on i mean this genocide
that's subsidized by my tax dollars
so what's the difference explain to us
you have the mainstream media cnn fox
news
nbc abc that type of media
and where we get our headlines where we
get much of the news
and then the type of journalism that you
do yeah there's
there's two warring warring media uh
you know industries here um one is the
corporate owned
u.s media essentially this is an
apparatus that acts as an extension
and an arm of the pentagon um basically
it tells us who our friends and foes are
and it's always basically demonized
palestine it's always
peddled the zionist line um you can see
that this is very apparent when you look
at someone like jeffrey goldberg who's
the editor-in-chief of the atlantic
who was actually a former idf prison
guard and then you could look at
something that's supposed to be this
impartial newswire that's then
editorialized by these publications
something like ap and reuters
when you had a woman who was just a
member of a palestinian student's
justice organization at her college and
she was
fired from ap for simply being a member
of this organization
and mind you this was after the ap
building was directly demolished by
israel
for no reason at all so war crime upon
war crime it doesn't matter
these agencies will bend to the will of
the zionist line and of course the u.s
empire's line because it all fits
together then you have the independent
media apparatus
that is independently funded grassroots
donor funded
places like empire files places i'm sure
like the dean show
um and we try to tell the perspective of
of victims i mean of these atrocities
around the world we try to uplift the
voices
of the people who are ignored um
who are you know basically just swept
under the rug when it comes to these
horrific policies that are being
perpetrated in our name
now before we go deeper into the subject
a lot of times this label gets thrown
out
anti-semitic anti-semitism i want to
bring on a israeli friend of mine
uh you might know him also uh he's also
an israeli jew
and he's doing some great work so i'm
going to bring him on real quickly a
video clip and then get your reaction to
this term
anti-semitic anti-semitism then another
claim that is often made and i'm sure
you hear this a lot
is that criticizing is the state of
israel or criticizing zionism
is anti-semitic so if you criticize
israel you're anti-semitic
which means you're racist
now this is a very strange claim for
several reasons first of all
most jewish people don't live in israel
many jewish people always opposed israel
many jewish people rejected zionism
so are they also anti-semitic what about
those jewish people
that's number one number two
so opposing israel is anti-semitic and
racist
in fact they're saying this more and
more today
so what does it mean when you support
israel is there a name for that
because if we support israel we support
a state
that has thousands of political
prisoners
if we support israel we support the
state
that has laws that discriminate against
the non-jews
if we support israel we support a state
that gives less water
to palestinians because they're not
jewish
if we support israel we support the
state that on a regular basis
as a policy kills civilians
palestinian civilians not by mistake not
as collateral damage but as a policy
so opposing all of that is anti-semitic
and supporting all of that is okay
how does that even make sense how is
supporting all of that
okay this is supposed to help the jews
this is supposed to help anyone so
it's very threatening for people to
criticize israel for many people because
they don't want to be called
anti-semitic but on the other hand the
whole
claim that it's anti-semitic is
completely absurd because criticizing
israel is the right thing to do
criticizing any racist regime is the
right thing to do regardless if they're
jewish or muslim or christian or
anything else
your comments on this term anti-semitic
is a good friend of mine i i really
revere him
and he really has broken it down very
lucidly and he did this recently on an
empire files podcast that we did
together where he talked about how
anti-semitism
is in the same broader ideology of white
supremacism and zionism
they are all hateful ideologies that are
founded
and premised on the otherization right
on
dehumanization of another people to
actually
call a state government that is
committing horrific atrocities
that is imprisoning 1.2 million people
in an open-air prison
that is perpetuating an illegal
occupation illegally annexing land
expelling people killing people
imprisoning people
torturing people employing an apartheid
state
two sets of laws for palestinians and
jews
that is anti-semitic to criticize a
government
i mean how is it islamophobic to
criticize saudi arabia for executing
prisoners or i'm sorry for executing
political protesters who are trying to
just protest their government of course
not
so why is it called anti-semitic to
simply criticize a government that is
engaged in absolutely atrocious policies
in our name
this is a tactic this is a tactic that
has been used and
weaponized against anti-racists against
progressives against people who really
are
um staunchly opposed to these policies
and that is why it has worked so well
because of course people who are
criticizing israel don't want to be
called anti-semitic of course
this is part why this is such a third
rail issue
why it is so taboo because you don't
want to be labeled an anti-semite
you don't want to be smeared and
slandered and have your career destroyed
because you're simply criticizing a
government
um so this has been a tactic used by
israel this has been
long employed and deployed and has
actually worked quite efficiently
um but i don't think it's working
anymore i don't think that the narrative
has been able to
be held in that way because for the last
20 years specifically israel has gone on
the offense
invading countries bombing gaza
relentlessly this is an open-air prison
where caged people are continuously
bombed all the things uh like ahead to
mimi
all of these moments that have happened
and then especially the great march of
return i think
really has has exposed israel as the
occupier as the violator
of human rights they can no longer claim
that they are on the defense and that
they are somehow protecting themselves
from
you know rabid anti-semites who want to
destroy them it's all this hypothetical
nonsense that's used
to essentially justify their horrific
acts
um and for the longest time progressives
have been scared
to go out front and center and say these
things because they are afraid of this
label but
again i mean it's time to flip this
narrative on its head and say
you are a defender of apartheid you are
a defender of war crimes
so now you have to defend that you can't
now come at us and say oh why do you
criticize israel are you anti-semitic no
no
no you are the apologist you are the
defender of apartheid and now
you need to be put on the defense about
why you do that
and so once we get that narrative going
which i feel like it already is i feel
like apartheid israel is
um facing the beginning at the end of
their regime and it's part and parcel
because of now
independent media palestinians being
able to film their reality with their
own eyes and israel no longer having
control
of the narrative anymore you know it's
interesting my my
guess that i brought on a couple weeks
ago who was also from the area
there by gaza uh when i brought this
term up he said they don't use that with
us
because it's interesting uh palestinians
are also semitic they speak a semitic
language they practice a semitic
religion islam submission to the creator
not the creation
so it's like to them they say it's funny
you know what i mean and they can't get
away with it
but they only push this uh to the
american public who's ignorant
of some of these things yeah it's a
trick we always
use it when from europe somebody is
criticizing israel then we bring up the
holocaust when in this country people
are criticizing israel then there are
anti-semitic exactly that's why you have
uh that's why you have all these israeli
officials speaking english
naftali bennett and netanyahu they're
very important figures because they are
speaking to us this is a propaganda
campaign
to manufacture consent with the american
public specifically
hebrews the national language of israel
these people are paraded around our
media specifically to speak to us
and to put this narrative out there and
it's quite fascinating once you realize
that
i want to get into another clip you were
in i believe it's called
you actually went down there you went
down to this area
in palestine you went to you visited
uh what's called the tolerance square is
that correct yeah in jerusalem
yeah so let's get into this clip and get
your reaction to some of the reactions
that you got
disease not think
that that the islam is uh
it's a very bad disease not
not just for israel for uh
all around the world we can see it
they think they they all have to be
islam if you're not islam they will kill
you
it's against the jews are the marry
arabs
because jews is a special nation that
god gave it to the jews
and we don't want jews to get mixed up
together with a different nation
i think israelis have to take over
and they have to kick them
kick them away it will be much better
not not to kill them just to
to go back to to arab countries
you can't deal with these people there's
no need to try there's no need to talk
to them
what we can do is when they they do
enough harm we retaliate that's war and
that's the situation that any jew lives
in israel has to deal
i think also that every arab that doing
a terrorism attack
we have to kill him and not because he's
the arab because he's a terrorist i
think he should
also kick out the family because it's
all begins with
you know education
whatever they teach the kids the kids it
does you know it's families
i may think that we
i think we should give them a country if
you're doing any problem you're just
going there to give them country then
it's going to be a
war between countries you know if
they're going to rockets we're going to
throw one big one and done
i don't think there's any answer to it
really there's only one way
like i would carpet bomb them you would
harp upon them
it's the only it's the only way you
could deal with it like or or
try to stop them a different way it
never worked
make a big dream and we need to kill a
harvest
[Laughter]
what does it mean for our audience some
people have never heard this term to
carpet bomb them what does that actually
mean
it means to basically liquidate an
entire area
of civilian infrastructure and housing
so
with just wanton bombing campaigns that
have no regard for human life at all
which is
pretty much exactly what we're seeing
the idf um
employ hiroshima nagasaki yeah yeah
that i mean that i mean that's that's a
of course a nuclear holocaust but i mean
you saw right there an israeli
citizen or an israeli settler basically
advocating that he said once we give
them a state we can just drop one giant
bomb
aka a nuclear bomb and just destroy the
entire area you know i was pretty
floored when i went into this this
region within 48
and talked just randomly to average
israelis on the street i mean
these were americans these were settlers
these were people from all walks of life
not cherry-picked at all and i think it
really just shows you even though it's
anecdotal i think it really is reflected
in
polling that this represents the
mainstream current of israeli society
you have a young girl laughing gleefully
actually
saying kill all arabs it's very
triggering
but this is what people think gleefully
endorsing genocide
to an american documentarian i mean if
this is what people will say on camera
what are they saying and advocating for
behind closed doors it was very very
disturbing to hear these interviews
because all we hear
you know as americans living in this
country this is completely sanitized
from us
we hear about israel being a democracy
we hear about human rights
you know we hear about israeli society
trying to push someone like netanyahu or
bennett i mean
that those are aberrations and outliers
that they don't represent the mainstream
of israeli society but in fact they do
they absolutely do they are an outgrowth
of where israeli society is at it's
increasingly fascistic and right-wing
and actually genocide is a mainstream
current
this is reflected all across israeli
society and it's very scary i mean we
just saw
we're seeing what's unfolding in sheikh
right now which is
um you know tens of thousands of people
marching through the old city
destroying muslim homes businesses
chanting death to error
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
uh to be a leftist in israel is a slur
um to be a leftist basically means that
you just want more humane
occupation it doesn't mean that you're
anti-zionist so
you know mikko has laid this out really
well about the composition of the
knesset and
how tokenized the couple arab seats are
but really the vast majority of
political parties and the vast majority
of people in general are zionist
they're unabashedly so and they believe
in the jewish supremacist state which
basically is predicated and premised
on the continuous expulsion of
indigenous peoples
and that is a genocide because basically
what it's trying to do is erase their
entire culture
you talked about how this is um i mean
this is known jimmy carter's talked
about american president anybody who's
actually gone down they're taking the
time to really you know visit the area
they talk about
it being an open-air prism uh they talk
about
miko pillow pellet brings us to light
and many uh jews actually
you have dr gata holocaust survivor
many who come out and it's not about
being muslim jew christians about just a
human you know if you have like yourself
i mean just the humanness comes out and
you see these atrocities babies just
being blown up you know
and like they were saying this carpet
bombing that happens you know
indiscriminate
it's just you know if you have a heart
if you're human this just
it just awakens you to want to speak out
and you have good people speaking out
like yourself
so um tell us when you
visited gaza so you talk about counting
calories refugee refugees that are not
allowed to leave like what does that
mean they're counting calories
yeah i mean this is this is basically
when we say this is an open-air prison
it really
is true because people are not allowed
to leave
this area it is a 25 by 5 mile strip of
land
that's essentially been cordoned off by
israeli authorities
alongside the egyptian military which
acts in compliance with israel
you need a permit to leave you need a
permit to get medical treatment that
you can't get within the territory so
for comparison if you get breast cancer
just 10 miles away in 48 so in israel
you have a 75
chance of survival if you are diagnosed
with the same cancer within the gaza
territory you have a 30
chance of survival that's the disparity
that we're talking about we're talking
about
no clean water the vast majority of
diseases within gaza are because of
diseased water that's not sanitized
because they continue to bomb their
water salination plants
food this was a policy that was written
up explicitly in israeli uh
government documents that said that they
wanted to
count calories so essentially just
provide just amount
just the the minimum amount of food to
get into gaza
so that there wouldn't be malnutrition
so to keep people just on the cusp
of being able to survive um electricity
they only have two to three hours of
electricity a day this seems like oh
you could survive that way it's very
hard i mean
um think about freezing meat you know
think about keeping
food cold uh electricity is as important
as the air we breathe
as someone who was in our documentary
says i mean he says it's humiliating
right the fact that they need to worry
every night about their children
lighting the house on fire because they
have to use candles
when we were getting the footage for
this documentary and now i was banned
for life from actually entering gaza i
was in the west bank for a month
and i tried to get into gaza i had all
the proper press credentials and
paperwork filled out and i was told by
the press ministry that i was an iranian
spy and a propagandist and that i was
banned for life from entering the
territory
which was devastating so i actually
worked with six journalists on the
ground to
direct the interviews to get the footage
that you see in gaza fights for freedom
which people can check out for free on
our youtube channel
and also go to gazafitsfreedom.com but
in this movie it's really an accurate
depiction of what this great march of
return was because what it reveals
and of course people are going to be
protesting and and resisting
right that that are living in this
besieged enclave
that are essentially continuously
tortured by the israeli government and
punished collectively that that's the
key is they are collectively punished
but the great march of return was so
such an incredible event because what it
showed
is what the israeli government will do
to peaceful marchers
because we always hear this conflation
of hamas shooting rockets and oh they
have the right to defend themselves
which they don't of course
but this instance 27 2018
2019 the great march of return where
thousands of people were going with bare
chests to this artificial border fence
that partitions them from their
ancestral lands
standing there with flags and they were
mowed down by israeli snipers
200 of them peacefully marching and this
wasn't just
people this wasn't just men of military
age
this was children directly targeted by
israeli snipers
this was medics administering medical
aid
this was journalists killed targeted
and people who were disabled these are
all violations of the geneva convention
even if this was a war between armies
these would be war crimes so what this
movie
is really what what our intent was
behind the movie was to really
kind of push the needle to hold israel
accountable in front of an international
war crimes tribunal
because that's exactly where they need
to go
people are seeing this is this actually
something that
people are wearing what does this
represent that is one shot two kills
this was a t-shirt that was issued by
members of the israeli apartheid defense
forces and this shows a pregnant woman
and they say one shot two kills because
this is how much they've dehumanized and
devalued palestinian life
they actually are advocating to kill a
pregnant woman to take out the unborn
baby
um this was not a one-off this was
something that was circulated throughout
the israeli military
in gaza fights for freedom you can see
that israeli snipers were actually
filming themselves
kill children who pose no threat to them
at all and
laughing cheering this is how much
this is kind of how sadistic this
mentality is i mean
when you are part of israeli society i
mean just like that guy
said in the clip he said it starts with
the education yeah it does it starts
from
birth the segregation the education
taught to hate and dehumanize the people
that you're ethnically cleansing
you have to you have to otherwise how
could you how could you embrace such a
nazi-like mentality as wearing that
shirt
i mean that's where we're at you know
america is a very racist society because
of the remnants of slavery
and genocide of the indigenous
population that happened hundreds of
years ago
right but we still have racist
institutions that are remnants of this
disturbing past well israel is
colonizing now
they're openly colonizing another people
killing expelling these people so of
course
can you imagine how prevalent racism is
it's part and parcel with zionism
zionism is racism
colonialism is racism this is happening
now
so people really need to wrap their
minds around the fact that this is this
is
their reality every single day and it's
very disturbing i mean where else in the
world is is anything like this happening
but because of this cover of impunity
that's given to them by the us empire
they continue to do it with no
consequences at all
let's get into our final clip and your
reaction and then we'll
go ahead and close it up bellam muhammad
who's uh one of the ufc fighters had on
his instagram
and uh i texted you that it's
we it's so again this is another thing
right so difficult to understand what's
actually going on there's so many
pro-israel people
that put their head in the sand and
don't want to look at some of these
atrocities and don't
want to look at some of the videos that
you sent me of soldiers shooting at
people
that are not doing anything right last
time when you talked about this
one of my email accounts was flooded
with
literally a chain letter with the same
letter like denouncing you and your lies
and your anti-semitic perspective
and your anti-israelis perspective
it was it was weird because it was the
same
email astroturf yeah
let's start with that term many people
don't know uh what this term astral
turfing is
can you explain that to us yeah so what
joe rogan
received because he basically received
the brunt end of the israeli lobby
campaign
so astroturfing basically appears that
something is organic and grassroots so
in this case it was
israeli lobby forces namely the
organization
stand with us which is an extension and
appendage of the israeli government
i mean this is why you see barry weiss
out there trying to debunk me
wherever i go on platforms that are big
enough like joe rogan she'll go on and
try to
you know debunk my claims she's received
money from stand with us in the israeli
government
but this letter campaign that was sent
in mass to joe rogan
pretended that it that it was from just
hundreds of different people
that were outraged at my appearance but
really what it was was a stock letter
that was sent out um essentially being
astroturfed
in that way and i think this is really
revealing
because they were so threatened by me
going on such a large platform talking
about palestine that they needed to
pull out all their cards right they also
produced a video
labeling me an anti-semite trying to
debunk my claims but what they did was
just
make themselves look ridiculous because
they basically just deny the existence
of the occupation
they ignore everything going on in gaza
and they just talk about how israel is a
democracy right and they ignore all of
these atrocities that are happening
outside their borders but
the joe rogan experience was really such
a shocking one because it showed you
how threatening how threatened they are
and to what extent they will
go they actually tried to lobby joe to
have an israeli government official come
on and debunk me
luckily he didn't do that and i'm glad
he talked about this on the on
the show because it shows you what
they'll do you know they won't let these
claims
stand they won't let people who are
going out there encountering the
narrative
they won't just let it happen without
trying to
put the hammer down hard and in my case
that's exactly what they did
so joe rogan i mean he was talking about
how you were sending him
some of these clips and he was
acknowledging
uh many of what's much of what's going
on he mentioned
muhammad ufc fighter um seeing some
things that he's posted
so he's pretty well educated on it and
you did that program people are so happy
to see you
on that program educating you know his
audience
do you think uh you'll be back on again
anytime soon
i think that we'll find out in the
coming weeks if i'm gonna come back on
um but joe is really really a great guy
um he's a friend of mine he really cares
about the issue
every time i've come on in the last
couple of years he's let me just have
the floor to talk about this and
you know hundreds of people if not
thousands of people have told me that
they have
found out about palestine that they have
changed their mind about the conflict
from
listening to my appearances on joe rogan
and that really
it means a lot um because people
criticize him a lot for not having
enough left-wing voices on
and sure that that might be a valid
critique but the fact that he's let me
have the floor
to to criticize israel on such an
enormous platform i think speaks volumes
about his integrity
and his willingness to stand up against
this i mean he said himself on the
program he said that's nazi germany
that's nazi germany when you have
t-shirts being printed that says one
shot two kills
targeting a pregnant woman when you see
video footage of israeli
soldiers happily executing children for
doing nothing
what else can you call that that's the
mentality that we're fighting against
and i appreciate you know everything
that you do for shedding a light on this
and
hopefully public consciousness can be
you know i i feel like it's really on
fire right now
and the latest assault on gaza was
really you know
i think a turning point i think that
we've reached a line in the sand that
um people know that this is apartheid we
have human rights watch which is
notorious for kind of both sides and
obfuscating the issue
we have members sitting members of
congress who have been
notoriously bad on this issue before of
course congress is the body that
that allows all this to happen that
subsidizes israeli apartheid but when
you have
several sitting members declaring that
this is apartheid
and all of these world bodies declaring
that this is apartheid when you have the
international criminal court announcing
that they are going to investigate war
crimes in these territories
that's a line that we can't draw back
from now
now everyone agrees this is apartheid so
now it's what can we do about it
how do we fight it how do we defeat it
and i think that's a huge huge thing a
shift in the overton window that is now
um we can't go back from that we can't
backpedal from that term so now it's a
matter of
how can we make apartheid fall and
that's exactly where we need to be
and again putting people on the defense
of why
are they defending apartheid why do they
defend these atrocities
please uh let uh joe give him a hello
from me
uh he actually wore one of my t-shirt
you know i teach martial art also he had
my team shirt resolving jiu jitsu he
wore one time on his show so
that's amazing that was cool for him all
right so we showed the video on you on
the streets
uh we just showed clips so what's that
called so people can actually get the
full version of that video what's that
called titled so people if they want to
everyday israelis express genocide to
abby martin i
highly encourage you to check out the
whole video it's on our youtube
playlist on empire files so subscribe to
us on youtube and then you can check out
our entire playlist reporting from
palestine
we have about a dozen or so videos that
are extremely revealing
from all across the west bank gaza
interviews with
israeli dissidents interviews with
palestinians that speak for themselves
and then of course our feature length
documentary gaza fights for freedom
about the great march of return
gaza fights for freedom that's your
newest documentary you directed it right
yes so people everybody if they want to
know about this
what's going on there they should watch
this documentary politicians people of
influence everyone should watch this
documentary and that's on your channel
yes it is and you can go to
gazafitsforfreedom.com to look to watch
it in arabic
subtitles as well god bless you your
brave soul
uh thank you so much it was really an
honor to have you on thank you so much
it was an honor to be on